la contraofensiva ucraniana continúa su
avance sobre objetivos claves este
domingo el edificio administrativo que
las autoridades prórrogas tienen en la
ciudad de doñés fue severamente dañado
en un bombardeo la entrada principal fue
convertida en escombros y vehículos
cercanos resultaron destruidos las
autoridades separatistas notificaron
heridos pero no lamentan fallecidos
fue un golpe directo el edificio está
seriamente dañado es un milagro que
nadie haya muerto
desde que no reclamaron aún la autoridad
de los hechos para Rusia ahora es el
momento de Elevar una investigación y
apunta a un ataque con misiles y Mars
entregados por Washington
todos los fragmentos serán enviados para
su examen luego se establecerá Qué tipo
de proyectil era se ha abierto un caso
penal las autoridades investigativas
están estudiando este incidente
ha estado controlado por fuerzas
prorusas de 2014 y junto a gerson lugans
y saprisha ha sido ilegalmente
anexionada recientemente tras unos
controvertidos referendos impulsados por
Moscú este ataque sucede en momentos en
los que la guerra aparece haber entrado
en una nueva fase de violencia Ucrania
avanza y recupera kilómetros cuadrados
de territorio en regiones ocupadas y
Rusia lanzó el mayor ataque con misiles
sobre diferentes ciudades ucranianas
desde el inicio de la invasión tras
acusar a Ucrania de un ataque terrorista
contra el puente de crimea